why did I get a peg I'm bit confused now
hey guys it's Adam you might have seen
me on a love island being half naked on
Instagram and trying to pick some heavy
stuff up off the floor
my name is Sam you might recognize me
also from loved islands MTV X and the
beach or just being a great DJ you know
you might been to one of my shows my
name is Joyce and today these beautiful
guys are going to teach me slang so that
I could get a British Bay oh right this
is a good one actually I know but it's
different for me that is for you so it
can be two things right okay
beard oh god is that like child fate
like when they look like they're like 18
what they're not somebody who is super
hot but is in a relationship no my one
would be in a sentence what we got for
bid today
why not fishing what have you got for
lunch today say he's from Newcastle what
you think see no I meant it for me
bait would be you're being a bit risky
you're being a bit out there you need to
calm down but he's got one of those
Facebook posts and he's tagged the girl
that he's like semi seeing on the sly
but he doesn't want anyone find out I
would text somebody my bro that beer
yeah well you've reckless reckless why
are you adding people on the Facebook
Facebook all the Facebook's I don't if I
know all these words Lee some of them in
like atom words no gadji yeah I know I
see daddy
so I'm cracking on to a girl in the club
and I'm have you got a gadget Oh have
you got a mom yeah so now if I go to the
London town you know I'm drinking my
beer at the pub yeah yeah and you fight
til you got a catchy you've got a gadget
girl I'll be like no so I'm picking up
the gadget you're picking up a guy G in
the club and taking bands bands no cash
cash money game no when you make it rain
on you know the girls who are dancing
them bottle popping money no say I'm
gonna go and pick up the Benz I do not
have Benz someone in this room could
have Benz you don't know what's going on
in London town any not even the word
bands what is burns so they'll be kids
yeah the Benz
[Music]
Bristol C's Bristol City Bristol Bristol
sees what is for some reason I don't
know if it's because Valentine's Day is
getting closer but I only think of like
x-rated things go x-rays go x-ray he
took me to Bristol cities no I'll give
you a clue okay one of the words you
it's a it's rhyming yeah
we love that so the the Bristol cities
they said they take one of the words in
it so see it rhymes so it's basically
it's called cockney rhyming slang
cockney rhyming slang is like you're at
mate are you doing oh that's kind of guy
I would love some more porridge next one
mug mug isn't that like a mean face like
I'm also using American playing it
that's point you know people be like you
mean mugging me that's New York yeah so
far Oh what would it mean it's just like
Oh like you're just like means your
faces mean looking at them like you want
to fight them similar yes you know I
said go you make me laugh come up like
make me laugh an idiot okay and then you
can then you can then extender and say
like are you mocking me alright this is
a good one this is a good one Klieman
how do you feel if you are Clement
you're like nervous you clam up no
there's so many different ways these
don't worry it's not x-rated don't worry
okay I know you like the x-ray well when
I'm thinking of the word claiming of
them being someone who gets really
nervous no I'm hungry
I'm plumbing are you ready buzz watches
butters give me like don't give me
senses or just give me more I'll give
you a hint I don't know for sure I don't
wanna give you I try news in a sentence
and then I'll say if you get in warm or
cold
oh the only thing I can think of I don't
know why my buddy it just feels like
food so I'll give you I'll give you an
example well I'm just walking down the
street and you know you see an ex
any luck and then luckily for you
they're looking buzz Oh crazy the ugly
yeah I don't like that one I'm like you
somebody's keep that one for the exes
yeah oh absolutely I already got mug and
butters y'all making my argument times
more better okay so this one's again a
Newcastle saying so where he's from
he probably does it better than me
though weii weii why I oughta know weii
weii man pet uh that's a phrase I'm
giving you now weii marques yi1 pets
it sounds like why did I get a pet uh
I'm baked cookies now you'd be like oh
like do you want to go get some food oh
you're hungry and I'd be like why I'm on
path like of course and um I don't need
to use weii because it's impact yeah I'm
trying to figure out there to say the
what if you go why I like you got the
boy I like yeah hell yeah why'd you want
to if you want to go out you wanna get a
shot I'd be like why I let's go
you think it's me yes right it's like
yeah like hell yeah oh yeah okay witty
painting so I say I say Joyce you're
painting right so the home
is that sex it should be sex but it's
not sex well if the whole thing is the
harm it's not the type of show is it you
could have the hump I could have fun you
could have the hump
I only have lady lumps I'm sorry I've
left the toilets here you're gonna have
the whole I want to fall in you're
annoyed you're annoying oh man I've got
the hump that's me 9 to 6 every single
day you always go home it's always on my
forehead go home okay tap tap oh no no
oh is it like the tap of beer no it's
like tap that ass is that it I've got a
few ex-girlfriends that opt
crazy
oh just raising the head
you say it's lost the plot Oh lost the
plot yeah do you say that yeah if I said
this one yet I'll write it this one this
one's good Newcastle won again this is
north yeah why yeah why I know this I'm
pulling out the recess like the
repressed memories in my mind if you go
in again where are you going
so you get some food I'm gonna pick the
Benz up and then I'm going yet are you
going home you're going home pick the
benzo gun in ya left the toilet seat up
you've got the right there's another one
used to be a kind of Bob what to do when
your favourites okay dead ting so we had
a painting mm-hmm
now we have a dead thing I think the
thing is like not hot when I first heard
it I thought it meant oh it's over it's
dead it's done so you can put thinking
pretty much combine the two so yeah dead
be light it's done it's done blah are
you still he's still seeing that guy you
know he's
don't ting you guys when I'm such a
journey together we really this was
emotional yeah when you're next to
London just give it's cool Wow hook you
up and we'll just be sitting there like
a couple of paintings yeah looking for
more painting
hey we're community of paintings you
know we're just a squad we're just a
squad
the paintings go up the pts piece yes
thank you squirt I'm done I'm done